the man who took over our last studio
reigning defending yeah dog
not much good to be here deal barn in
the house good to see you guys today on
fight on the kids much younger more
handsome a little bit of a southern
twang and a mullet who made a talent
yeah this isn't a mullet first of all
gender-neutral haircut it's the only way
I'm getting work these days with this
haircut well you know and you love like
it look at you I don't know what you'd
call my you know I got my haircut in San
Jose and it might like this old-school
like gangster dude he goes bro you look
like John Gotti now I don't know if
that's the look I'm going for Matt
murderers cut yeah he goes he goes
everyone wants to do it because I always
get a fade you know I get faded up
usually high and tight yeah and he goes
that's what the kids are doing man you
let me do it proper I'll make you look
like Mad Men yeah he gave you that
prison cut yeah I was again I don't want
that man but I just shut my mouth and
took it yeah well that's up for
definitely that prison cut thing where
you get who are you get you know that I
get my cut locally here and I get mine
cut uh almost anywhere I am I'll get it
cut locally
I prefer local cuts great clips yeah
it's like a local establishment where
people are struggling you know cuz I
like when somebody cuts my hair if it
looks bad and I look at the person that
cut it and they look like [ __ ] I'm like
you know that's how it works that job
this rolled yeah cuz I don't you tell
them you like hey tight on the sides
party in the back and he's in the front
well you know I got here is you I got
hair rejuvenation surgery yeah I got
part of my mullet taken out and put in
the front and no one's ever done that
ever ever I don't think and I didn't
need it no you don't need you have great
has even grown in yet either
oh oh so we're waiting for it yeah what
are you gonna do it's gonna grow in your
eyes bangarang Brom have banks forever
dude I'm gonna rescue rescue rescue an
orphans off a hair ships bro imma be
Rufio II what yeah I don't know it we'll
see man I'm excited about you know the
thing is I have this man that cuts it
and he how much you charge you for a
nice cut like that probably nineteen
fifty or twelve ms-20 that's a good deal
eighteen dollars when I met him
yuuma tip yeah I give him six to eight
dollars solid tip I think cash yeah
I'll turn on low tip him credit
depending on how I'm feeling and what's
going on with him and how a man his wife
always fighting so if I have to hear
about that [ __ ] nine four dollars I
agree yeah I met your therapist say that
[ __ ] I got my own problems man I'm not
at there for some one guy with a bad
haircut
yeah and how often do you see him mmm we
text a little bit easier he's a real
moody ah there's only new guy yeah
you're that loyal umm yeah man yeah that
golden retriever dude I'll run you know
what I'm saying I'll lay by his great
when he dies but he's next to a pair of
scissors yeah you know I may be a video
on you on Facebook look what the golden
retriever did he'll never forget the man
that used to trim him and he runs out
there but even though he's a shitty
barber you just [ __ ] right and died
with his dude he's horrible dude and he
has the smallest head - this man is the
smallest hit nice to date a girl with a
small head when I was in when I was in
my 20s and this girl the smallest head
did and her hair made it look like her
head was regular-sized like them it's
tiny but if you would start like kissing
her and touch it my grabbing her head or
anything could almost yeah you could
almost you could touch like the back of
like the base of her neck like that
little part that end in in the back of
her neck and then all the way in between
the front of her it's just a little tiny
mouse he thing and then regular body
regular body it was like is like the
movie Beetlejuice where they sprinkle
dust you ever hear that regular body but
she had that yes yeah they're real just
I don't know what kind of head it was
just yeah tiny head tiny brain why would
I give that to you as it's a gift